eine anonyme Quelle schickt uns einen
Hinweis
150 Zwangsarbeiter seien vor ein paar
Tagen vom Zoll entdeckt worden ein Teil
von ihnen sei hier in Knittlingen einer
Kleinstadt in der Nähe von Karlsruhe
untergebracht worden
in einem baufälligen Hotel voller
Kakerlaken
wir treffen 40 serbische Arbeiter ihr
Chef ein Subunternehmer in der
Getränkelogistik der seit Jahren in
Deutschland lebt wurde vom Zoll
verhaftet die Behörden zogen auch die
Pässe der Arbeiter ein so blieb ihnen
nichts übrig als vorerst in ihre
Unterkunft zurückzukehren niemand kann
deutsch eine Übersetzerin hilft per
Telefon
Claudia Robbe kümmert sich um die
Arbeiter für eine Hilfsorganisation das
heißt man hat ihn 1500 versprochen und
was haben sie bekommen
[Musik]
halbe Stunde bezahlt die Zustände sind
Katastrophen haben ein Geld ich selbst
mache den Job seit 15 Jahren habe das so
extrem noch nie erlebt also mit so
vielen Betroffenen von Menschenhandel
also das Problem was die Leute hatten
dass sie für ihre Fahrt hierher schon
Schulden aufgenommen haben und dass sie
dann kein Mindestlohn erhalten haben
dass sie mehr als 14 15 Stunden arbeiten
mussten am Tag sieben Tage die Woche das
wenn sie krank waren das nicht sein
durften dass sie noch Strafe zahlen
mussten wenn sie krank waren
die Staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt wegen
menschenhandels-
Nikola Vasic lebt seit sechs Monaten
hier
für diese Unterkunft habe ihm der
Subunternehmer auch noch 200 Euro vom
Lohn abgezogen berichtete
war bis man sich gewaschen und gegessen
hatte war es spät wir hatten bloß vier
Stunden pro Nacht zum Schlafen und
Erholen ich fühle mich betrogen man hat
mir 5,50 € pro Stunde als
Einstiegsgehalt versprochen und das
alles legal sei dass ich angemeldet bin
so wurde mir das gesagt aber das stimmt
da alles nicht wir wurden total betrogen
warum machen Menschen so etwas mit
Bojana rajacic hatte sich auf eine
facebook-annonce gemeldet nach
Telefonaten nahm sie den vermeintlich
lukrativen Job an wurde mit einem
kleinen Bus nach Deutschland gebracht
bald wurde ihr klar worauf sie sich
wirklich eingelassen hatte
[Musik]
stellen Sie sich vor Sie arbeiten zwei
Schichten hintereinander ja wirklich
zwei Schichten ganze 16 Stunden zwei
Schichten von je acht Stunden wir drei
Frauen haben den ganzen Tag
Getränkekisten geschleppt das ist
anstrengend das ist körperlich und
psychisch anstrengend
habe sich in Serbien 500 Euro geliehen
um den ersten Monat in der Unterkunft
die Anfahrt aus Serbien und die
Arbeitskleidung zu zahlen
sie blieb um ihre Schulden zu begleichen
erzählt sie trotz allem
erst nach etwa einem Monat bekam die
Arbeiter ihre Pässe von den Behörden
zurück verbunden mit einer
ausreiseaufforderung innerhalb von
wenigen Tagen sollten Sie raus aus
Deutschland dabei hatten sie nicht
einmal Geld für rückfahrtickets ich
versuche ein Busticket zu kriegen für
euch beide von Karlsruhe
okay
am Mittwoch ja morgen ist voll Mittwoch
abgenommene abgeschobene Opfer
Gewerkschafter Schwertmann kritisiert
das widerspreche allen internationalen
Abkommen die Deutschland unterzeichnet
hat
da ist eigentlich steht überall drin
dass die Opfer sicher untergebracht
werden dass sie versorgt werden dass Sie
beraten werden ganz wichtig also die
müssen ihre Rechte kennen also diese
Situation diese geschildert haben die
kriegen ihre Pässe abgenommen haben
keine Ahnung was mit denen passiert aber
wenn diese Zeugen immer sozusagen in
Gefahr stehen selber verurteilt zu
werden wegen aufenthaltsrechtlicher
Vergehen oder anderen dann werden sie
sich nicht für Zeugenaussagen zur
Verfügung stellen
uns werden Aufnahmen zugespielt die
zeigen wie die serbischen Arbeitskräfte
Getränkekisten sortieren
sie arbeiten bei einem
getränke-logistiker der sagt er habe den
Werkvertrag mit dem Subunternehmer mit
sofortiger Wirkung beendet und habe im
Ermittlungsverfahren lediglich
zeugenstatus
ja es ist tatsächlich so also wenn die
tatsächlich ein anderes Unternehmen
Anfragen um Leiharbeiter also
Leiharbeitsunternehmen zum Beispiel
Anfragen schickt uns mal hier Leute dann
kann man tatsächlich also die das
Unternehmen dafür nicht nicht haftbar
machen
die Staatsanwaltschaft bestätigt sie
ermittle nicht gegen den
getränkelogistiker mit seinem
Werkvertrag der Subunternehmer hingegen
ist in Untersuchungshaft und was ist mit
seinen Helfern
[Musik]
wir folgen der facebook-spur nach
Serbien
von dort wurden die Arbeitskräfte
angelockt
in der Annonce steht ein Name den wir
zunächst nicht zuordnen können und eine
Telefonnummer
die Nummer wurde abgemeldet
wir suchen weitere Hinweise und
kontaktieren die Arbeitskräfte die
inzwischen wieder nach Serbien
zurückgekehrt sind
wir treffen Nicola Vasic wieder mit dem
Geld aus Deutschland hatte er für sein
Zuhause große Pläne
also ich hatte das so vor ich wollte mit
dem Geld einen Schweinestall bauen
Schweine kaufen diese Ecke da hinten
ausbessern das Dach reparieren eben
alles ein bisschen hübsch machen
für sechs Monate Arbeit in Deutschland
hatte einen Bruchteil vom erwarteten
Lohn bekommen statt zu renovieren
sammelt der Altmetall
ich habe dieses Geld verdient aber sie
haben uns die letzten zwei Monatslöhne
einfach nicht ausbezahlt das belastet
mich meine Lebensgefährtin sagt dass ich
nachts aufschrecke auch jetzt noch
auch Bojana rajacic ist wieder zu Hause
in ihrer Wohnung mit dem Geld aus
Deutschland wollte sie die Heizkosten
und Tennistraining führen 17-jährigen
Sohn bezahlen einen erfolgreichen
Nachwuchsspieler stattdessen hat sich
Schulden
ich war unglücklich ich konnte meinem
Sohn nicht mal Schokolade mitbringen
ich habe die Unterkunft als letzte
verlassen mir war nicht nach heimkehren
hat Screenshots von den betrügerischen
Facebook Annoncen die mittlerweile
gelöscht sind damit finden wir dann doch
noch den Mann der sie und viele andere
mit falsch Versprechen nach Deutschland
gelockt haben soll er wohnt nur ein paar
Kilometer weiter
ist
Facebook
er bestätigt uns gegenüber Arbeitskräfte
zu jener baufälligen Unterkunft in
Deutschland gefahren zu haben aber dass
er Facebook Annoncen aufgegeben hat das
streite der ab wir haken bei mehreren
Behörden in Serbien nach doch die
reagieren nicht auf unsere Anfrage
also kontaktieren wir eine
Hilfsorganisation die sich um Opfer von
arbeitsausbeutung kümmert
Lockangebote über Facebook sein typisch
in den Milieu
insgesamt betrachtet ist Menschenhandel
eine Form der organisierten Kriminalität
und so sollte es auch in
Gerichtsverfahren beurteilt werden
aber leider passiert das oft nicht vor
allem wenn die Behörden die Verbindungen
zwischen den Bandenmitgliedern nicht
nachweisen können
[Musik]
es gibt also wenig Hoffnung für bojaner
rajacic und alle anderen Betroffenen
dass die Hintermänner zur Rechenschaft
gezogen werden